oggi mi vedete al centro sorridente
insieme a un gruppo di giovani italiani
altrettanto sorridenti per spiegarvi
meglio il senso di questi sorrisi vi
devo raccontare una storia questo
ovviamente non cellulare tutti noi
abbiamo questo strumento ormai sempre
con noi
sì adesso prenderlo scaravento per terra
probabilmente si rompe e anche e voi
quest'anno da fare a rompere un
cellulare probabilmente appunto
succederà in voi diversi tipi di
emozioni stupore oppure fastidio
finirebbe lì sì adesso dissi un calcio a
questi schermi
forse la reazione sarebbe un po diversa
probabilmente vi arrabbierete anche gli
organizzatori ancora di più perché
creerei un danno a qualcosa che non è
solo mia ma in qualche modo appartiene a
questa struttura è inoltre creerebbe un
danno alle persone che che seguiranno me
sì adesso sisti da qui e con un piccolo
nemi dirigesse verso la torre e crearsi
dei danni a questa torre la reazione
credo che sarebbe ancora più forte da
parte vostra no come mai
perché questo danno ovviamente non
riguarderebbe solo a me nel mio
cellulare che ha un valore assolutamente
relativo o questi schermi che hanno un
valore per l'università per la comunità
di persone che sono qui questo è un
valore non solo per tutti noi per la
città di pisa per l'italia probabilmente
ha valore per tutta l'umanità questo è
un concetto che che risale che sia in
qualche modo creato costituito definito
tanto tempo fa l'uomo ha sempre avuto
l'esigenza di andare al di là dei propri
limiti delle proprie frontiere in tanti
modi ne raccontava the alcuni prime
certamente esprimendosi esprimendo il
city attraverso diversi linguaggi e
quello chiaramente linguaggio che nei
secoli è stato di fini
artistico è stato sicuramente uno dei
primi linguaggi che l'uomo ha
sperimentato ne abbiamo tante
testimonianze tante forme di arte
qualche modo un'elevazione che l'uomo
cercava di raggiungere sperimentando
linguaggi concetti dei simboli e questo
ovviamente nel tempo nei secoli ha
creato tanto tanta bellezza dato quella
che noi ad oggi definiamo bellezza tanti
luoghi che se qualcuno da li e li tocca
qualche modo da tocca anche noi ciascuno
di noi si attiva dentro di noi un
sentimento che anche se non siamo mai
stati p o non siamo mai stati p sappiamo
che se qualcuno crea un danno a questi
luoghi con promette questa bellezza
compromettere l'armonia di queste opere
d'arte di questo patrimonio crea un
problema anche a noi
questo perché addirittura di questo
patrimonio a noi molto spesso abbiamo
creato vere e proprie riserve come i
musei dove abbiamo addirittura raccolto
più opere più bellezza diverse di
diversi creatori definiamoli così e
abbiamo creato dei veri e propri tempi e
questo è vero ovviamente per l'arte
visiva ma è vero che per i tanti
linguaggi artistici
pensiamo alla musica che oggi celebriamo
ancora oggi in tanti modi la musica che
hanno scritto tanti artisti compositori
musicisti e che ancora oggi viviamo in
alcuni luoghi che per noi sono luoghi
importanti fondamentali
pensiamo ovviamente alla scrittura la
letteratura e libri e quindi alla
trasmissione del sapere
ma perché ci si attiva questo sentimento
molto spesso di appartenenza di legame a
questa bellezza
vogliamo decidere è universale solo
quando questa bellezza si trasforma in
qualcos'altro
questa è la moschea di aleppo in siria
che è stata assolutamente distrutte
dalla barbarie di da esse dei terroristi
e di tutti i conflitti ovviamente in
atto in quelle in quelle aree questa
questa immagine ci fa male si fa male
per tanti motivi ovviamente perché
assieme a questa immagine si
accompagnano di psi quattro sì che
ovviamente non ha senso vedere di vite
spezzate ma che abbiamo che è successo
qualcosa quando crollano delle pietre
quelle pietre ghilini è crollato un
pezzo anche di noi
di questo ne abbiamo tanta esperienza in
tanti modi
purtroppo nella storia dell'uomo
pensiamo qui vicino firenze 1966
l'alluvione famoso alluvione che mise
sotto sopra la città più recentemente il
terremoto in il terremoto in nepal che
ha distrutto con grandissima violenza
dei dei siti archeologici straordinari
pensiamo agli eventi drammatici che
hanno colpito nuovamente del nostro
centro italia quest'estate e che ancora
una volta non solo hanno stroncato tante
vite ma hanno fatto venir giù tanti
luoghi d'arte luoghi storici o non solo
eventi naturali insieme alla follia
dell'uomo come in afghanistan nel 2001
quando i talebani
cioè sero brillare completamente una
statua di buddha altra oltre 20 metri
più recentemente per tanti folli totali
che hanno preso a picconate opere d'arte
in iraq in siria perché le hanno prese
articolata
perché volevano distruggere quelle opere
millenaria probabilmente non sapevano
neanche cosa stessero colpendo da un
punto di vista diciamo storico artistico
dal momento che sono assolutamente
sappiamo bene diciamo che tipo di uomini
stiamo parlando eppure avevano capito
una cosa e la bellezza commettere paura
li spaventa la conoscenza il sapere i
valori che ci sono dietro quei luoghi
che sono stati conservati per migliaia e
migliaia di anni
anche semplicemente attiva analisi
quanti ne assistiamo in italia io vengo
da una città
roma che piena di come sapete di
patrimonio di opere d'arte
eppure c'è qualcuno che si diverte a
sfregiarle perché questa scrivere sul
colosseo per noi vedere queste immagini
tra un po di sorpresa no perché nessuno
fa mai perché non è tutto imbrattato il
call se come tanti muri o no ricorderete
piazza di spagna hooligans con un po
troppo birra in corpo che si sono
scatenati hanno sfondato una fontana del
bernini
perché tutti i giorni non è non è sporca
quella fontana ma invece è pulita e
nessuno si permette di sporcarla per chi
è dentro ognuno di noi c'è quel
sentimento di cui vi parlavo team che
quando succede qualcosa che altera che
l'armonia per la bellezza
interveniamo interveniamo subito se
alziamo appunto firenze sono gli angeli
del fango giovani volontari come voi
come noi che semplicemente hanno sentito
bisogno di andare lì tirare fuori opere
d'arte dal fango salvare i volumi della
biblioteca nazionale di firenze i nostri
vigili del fuoco che stanno facendo un
lavoro straordinario insieme tutte le
altre forze dell'ordine nel centro
italia salvando dalle chiese crollate le
opere d'arte che ancora sono integre
semplici cittadini a kathmandu che hanno
perso tutto ma hanno sentito l'esigenza
di rimettere un mattone di suor l'altro
in uno dei siti archeologici più
importanti
ovviamente i professionisti che con la
loro capacità
riescono a ristabilire la bellezza
integrità delle nostre prevert
banalmente togliere una scritta ma
toglierla subito perché quella scritta
non può rovinare quella bellezza di quel
luogo persone che addirittura danno la
propria vita come il direttore del museo
e del sito archeologico di palmira in
siria rapito dai membri di da essi ha
dato la vita pur di non dire dove aveva
nascosto alcuni reperti che desse volerà
distrugge e addirittura quando le cose
non si possono ricostruire come in parte
di palmira beh noi noi uomini ogni tanto
sentiamo il bisogno di riprodurre le
cose belle anche solamente a livello
simbolico come è stato fatto con la
riproduzione di quest arco nalco marco
di palmira andato distrutto che è stato
sempre il giro di alcune grandi capitali
europee
firenze perché piazzare quell'arco li
vuol dire
puoi anche distruggere altri 100 archi
ma i valori la storia le tradizioni
ideali che ci sono dietro quel tipo di
di storia non li distrugge rai ma la
stessa cosa in afghanistan hanno deciso
di non ricostruire un buddha grazie alla
tecnologia hanno proiettato l'immagine
di quella che è stato le stradali
ecco questi sono tutti i valori principi
promossi da una grande organizzazione
internazionale e questa è una foto
altrettanto sotto in mente londra 1941
42 nazisti bombardarono la città fa un
certo effetto di una grande città che
conosciamo così bene
bombardata e solo 75 anni fa succedeva
anche questo in quegli anni alcuni dei
ministri dell'educazione di alcuni paesi
europei antifascisti antinazisti
sentirono l'esigenza di di fare qualcosa
anche loro assieme ovviamente a il mondo
della della politica e della diplomazia
che in quegli anni cercava di dare una
risposta a questo evento ovviamente
drammatico tra i più drammatici della
storia dell'uomo per mondiale beh loro
pensavano che quello era forse nel
momento in cui avrebbero dovuto mettere
in campo uno sforzo comune anche dal
punto di vista dell'educazione della
cultura dell'istruzione perché credevano
pensavano che quel grande
scombussolamento di valori gli ideali
che aveva creato così tanto conflitto
violenza odio tra gli uomini
dipendesse anche dalla formazione degli
uomini stessi dell'istruzione
dell'educazione che ovviamente doveva
cominciare in qualche modo ad andare
sullo stesso binario
e cosa fecero questi signori crearono
dell'organizzazione insieme ad altri 20
paesi
appena terminata la guerra 45 46 20 25
paesi del mondo tra cui alcuni paesi che
probabilmente noi europei non ci
aspetteremmo intervenire su un progetto
come questo come ad esempio saudi
arabian sudafrica furono tra i primi a
dire abbiamo bisogno di costruire un
organismo sovranazionale che promuova
strategie a livello globale di tutela
del patrimonio artistico di crescita del
livello di formazione delle popolazioni
di sviluppo delle scienze e il preambolo
della costituzione dell'unesco dice
delle parole molto semplice ma molto
importanti dice poi che le guerre
cominciano le menti degli uomini e nelle
menti degli uomini che si devono
costruire le difese della pausa l'unesco
molto spesso è percepita come
un'organizzazione molto distante ogni
tanto camminando vediamo un loghino
soprattutto in italia attaccato a
qualche colonna qualche ingresso di sito
archeologico
non è un logo astratto è una struttura
che promuove tanti programmi a livello
mondiale ed è impegnata appunto nel
campo dell'educazione della cultura
delle scienze umane e sociali delle
scienze naturali e nel campo della
comunicazione dell'informazione uno
degli impegni più importanti di unesco
per il quale ovviamente conosciuto di
più è l'impegno legato al patrimonio
mondiale nel 1972
l'unesco le nazioni che hanno aderito
nel tempo calo n'esco ormai oltre 170
hanno stabilito di creare una lista
mondiale di siti di luoghi naturali
culturali archeologici storici che di
diritto
dovevano essere riconosciuti di
straordinaria rilevanza importanza non
solo per il paese specifico dove quel
sito hicks si trova a per tutta
l'umanità quindi ad oggi ci sono oltre
1.050 due siti di cui 800 14 siti
culturali
quindi pensiamo il centro storico di
roma centro storico di firenze piazza
dei miracoli creatisi e 203 naturali
sempre rimanendo in italia le dolomiti
let me
come vedete diversi di questi siti sono
in danger in pericolo che tipo di
pericolo quello che vedevamo prima
spesso sono siti che si trovano in zone
di guerra o pericolo dovuto a e
possibili eventi climatici che possono
scatenare come è stato in nepal la
distruzione di questi siti
l'unesco però nel tempo ha capito che
doveva valorizzare doveva accendere un
faro non solo su
quello che viene definito il patrimonio
tangibile materiale un luogo ma anche su
quello che ha definito un patrimonio
intangibile
cos'è il patrimonio intangibile sono
tutta quella serie di forme di
tradizione dei linguaggi artistici ma
non solo di know how che l'uomo nei
secoli ha sviluppato in tutto il mondo e
quindi ad esempio dal 2001 l'unesco ha
cominciato a definire una lista appunto
di patrimoni immateriali
tra questi gli italiani l'arte della
liuteria cremona fare i violini e
qualcosa che non appartiene solo a
cremona o sola l'italia è un'arte ormai
centenaria che ha consegnato uno
strumento straordinario il violino la
famiglia poi degli archi a tutto il
mondo attraverso il quale ci esprimiamo
attraverso il quale creiamo delle
emozioni che che parlano appunto tutto
il genere umano
cosa fa unesco in questi anni così
complicati fa molto
in realtà come ben capite è una
istituzione che sta tornando ad essere
centrale a livello internazionale
questa è la campagna che unesco ha
lanciato due anni fa a livello globale
unit foreste uniti per il patrimonio che
cosa fa questa campagna lavora su
più fronti per riaccendere
quell'emozione che ci ricordiamo di
provare solamente quando prendono a
picconate una statua quando arriva un
terremoto e butta giù una chiesa ecco
quella è un'emozione che invece dobbiamo
coltivare quotidianamente probabilmente
da dire noi italiani in particolare
ancora di più
lei è la direttrice mondiale di innesco
la persona che coordina in prima linea
le attività alle azioni di unesco a
livello internazionale che sta mettendo
una firma su un pezzo di carta 36 di
carta molto importante per l'unesco ma
anche e soprattutto per noi italiani
la firma che è stata messa l'anno scorso
a roma
e su quel documento si è preso un
impegno noi italiani un bell'impegno
non so se sapete noi italiani abbiamo un
gruppo altamente specializzato
all'interno dei carabinieri per la
tutela del patrimonio culturale
aspetta un attimo su ai carabinieri che
centrano patrimonio nucleare c'entrano
molto e hanno sviluppato anche una
professionalità sulla lente eccellente
non solo ovviamente aiutano a recuperare
opere d'arte trafugate o comunque ad
evitare la criminalità
diciamo applicata al mondo dell'arte ma
addirittura stanno dando un grande aiuto
anche a livello internazionale e quindi
la direttrice generale dell'unesco ha
detto firmando quel documento abbiamo
bisogno di voi abbiamo bisogno
dell'italia degli italiani nelle vostre
capacità per far sì che questo
patrimonio che in alcune parti del mondo
e messo in pericolo anche dalla
criminalità del terrorismo
beh aiutateci dateci una mano e hanno
creato quella che è stata definita la
task force dei caschi blu della cultura
bellissimo concetto ed è bello vedere e
sapere che ad esempio ci sono anche
giovani donne
lei è l'unica giovane donna michelangela
stefano della task force che sta dando
un grandissimo contributo come donna e
come professionista al recupero di opere
d'arte messe diciamo in impegni
piccolo e lei è particolarmente attiva
nell'area del centro italia ed è bello
vedere come stiamo scalando diciamo
questa collaborazione arrivando fino al
consiglio di sicurezza delle nazioni
unite
uno dei luoghi e si prendono risoluzioni
decisioni assolutamente centrali a
livello mondiale
beh e grazie anche al generale di questa
task force che le nazioni unite
recentemente e marzo hanno approvato una
risoluzione che impegnerà ancora di più
tutti gli stati che aderiscono le azioni
gran parte del mondo
nell'impegno alla tutela del patrimonio
e noi noi giovani noi italiani che
possiamo fare e nel 2011
ero in questa sala che la sala
principale di unesco a parigi
l'unesco mondo alla sede a parigi è una
sala molto bella dove si siedono tutti i
rappresentanti dei paesi che hanno
aderito all unesco come dicevo prima
oltre 160 170 e non esco ogni anno
organizza un ritrovo momento come questo
per fare incontrare i giovani di questi
paesi
via nel 2011 fu il delegato italia in
quel momento capii che c'era un
opportunità un opportunità di dare un
contributo non da diplomatico da
carabiniere o da professionista da
archeologo contributo come giovanni
cittadino che in qualche modo prova
questa emozione di cui vi parlavo prima
che tornando a roma
stimolato ispirato da da quel da quelle
storie da quegli incontri con tanti
altri giorni di altri paesi che
provavano con la stessa emozione ho
detto beh forse possiamo fare qualcosa
anche noi qui in italia e quindi abbiamo
creato un gruppo dei giovani dell'unesco
italia cioè abbiamo messo insieme oltre
300 giovani tra i 20 e 35 anni
i giovani studenti ricercatori
professori manager culturali che
dedicano parte del loro tempo della loro
vita ovviamente in formula assolutamente
volontaria
per aiutare l'unesco in italia a
realizzare delle iniziative e dei
progetti che aiutano ci aiutino a
promuovere i valori di cui stiamo
parlando
tra questi vi cito solamente un progetto
che abbiamo realizzato grazie al
sostegno all'attenzione alla
condivisione del nostro ministero
dell'istruzione che ci sta portando in
tutte le scuole d'italia in ciascuna
regione stiamo portando questi temi
parlando dell'unesco da giovani a
giovani che lo stiamo facendo anche qui
a pista tra l'altro e stiamo incontrando
migliaia di giovani e stiamo cercando di
risvegliare in loro non solo un
interesse ma anche una consapevolezza
che molto spesso non c'è dell'importanza
di quello che è una statua una torre un
museo che non è solamente un luogo dove
le cose si conservano o dove tu non puoi
fare nulla perché se fai qualcosa rovini
no puoi anche interagire con quelle
opere d'arte puoi anche interagire con
quei musei questo sta anche le nostre
amministrazioni forse facilitare diciamo
vivere partecipativo di quei luoghi e
quindi ragazzi il messaggio è anche
molto semplice le cose possono nascere
in maniera veramente spontanea e
arrivare laddove se ne ce n'è bisogno e
quindi come vedete la signora che ha
messo la firma su una cosa così
importante ci ha incontrato e noi
abbiamo dato il nostro contributo del
nostro e brass nei nostri bei la nostra
voce a quella campagna che vi dicevo
l'unesco strato muovendo a livello
internazionale
e questa era la foto due partiti ieri
eravamo a parigi siamo andati a parigi a
presentare a tutti gli altri stati in
quella sala che mi facevo vedere prima
la nostra storia e la cosa sorprendente
ci hanno detto nessuno lo aveva mai
fatto nessuno aveva creato un comitato
giovani con 300 persone in unesco che
aiuta le nostre istituzioni italiane e
internazionali a promuovere questi dei
tra i giovani
quindi quello che ci hanno detto è ci
sta aiutando a ridurre questa distanza
tra la nostra abitazione così grande ma
poi alla fine forse a volte poco capace
di essere vicino dal dire alle persone a
cui vogliamo essere vicino ai giovani
quindi questo è il messaggio della
storia e la motivazione di quei sorrisi
ieri abbiamo dimostrato che alla fine
anche noi giovani italiani possiamo dare
un contributo per il nostro paese ea
livello internazionale e non ci
dimentichiamo mai che dipende da noi
cambiare le cose
grazie
[Applauso]